the entire Donald Trump charity scam is
falling apart
last year Donald Trump's charity was
fined because they violated federal
rules on what's called self-dealing and
now the entire Donald Trump Charitable
Foundation is being dissolved but that's
actually something that Donald Trump
promised to do when he was elected to
try to avoid conflicts of interest that
announcement may have been carefully
timed I think is what I'm trying to say
to take attention away from renewed
interest in the charitable dealings of
Eric Trump's charity Trump's son Eric
Trump has a charity and that charity has
been caught funneling cancer donations
for kids to Trump businesses and we told
you that this was likely going on last
June or July I believe it was there was
a story in Forbes about it it has again
flared up and Eric Trump's attorney is
sort of reiden eyeing these allegations
and the allegations are that people
thought they were donating to st. Jude's
Children's Research Hospital by playing
in various golf tournaments at Trump
golf courses and it was believed that
use of the golf course was being donated
by the Trump Organization Donald Trump
Eric Trump whoever ultimately gets to
make that decision but we have since
learned that hundreds of thousands of
dollars of donations to those events
were going to the Trump golf course to
pay for the use of the courses for the
fundraisers IRS filings for the Eric
Trump foundation in 2012 show that just
under sixty thousand dollars were spent
on an annual golf Invitational
fundraiser helped at trump National Golf
Club in Westchester New York that number
ballooned by 2013 to over two hundred
and thirty thousand dollars and to
nearly two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in 2014 according to IRS filings
now only some part of that we believe
went back to the Trump Organization but
the cost of that event has ballooned
rapidly this actually appears to be more
related to Donald Trump than to Eric
trump because reportedly it was Donald
Trump who her
that they were not charging for the use
of the golf courses for these charitable
golf events and Donald Trump said oh no
no no we've got to start charging for
that so I want I want to restate that it
seems that Eric Trump was doing the
right thing which is hey it's my charity
we own these golf courses we're not
going to bill for the use of the golf
courses for my own charity and then it
was Donald Trump who said Eric or to
whoever you've got to start charging for
the use of our golf courses for your
charity event and if there's any
indication that the allegations are true
it's that they aren't being denied by
Eric Trump's lawyer Eric Trump's lawyer
put out a statement saying during the
past decade Eric trump the Eric Trump
foundation has raised over sixteen point
three million dollars for st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital while
maintaining an expense ratio of just
twelve point three percent the Eric
Trump foundation was also responsible
for building a twenty million dollar ICU
which treats the sickest children
anywhere in the world suffering from the
most catastrophic terminal illness it
doesn't matter what your expense ratio
is if the charity president is billing
services from his own business and
collecting hundreds of thousands of
dollars from it and you can tell when
these denials are not denials when you
have allegation you funneled hundreds of
thousands in donations to your business
and the denial is here's a list of nice
things that we've done over time this
should in rage everyone but particularly
anybody who has been touched by cancer
or has fundraised around cancer which
I've done right as some of you know my
dad has been living with multiple
myeloma which is a type of blood cancer
for nine years and I've done fundraisers
and I've run 5ks and I go to people and
say well you sponsor me to run this race
for cancer research and if I found out
that the organizer of the event had a
business that they were funneling money
into when I'm putting myself out there
emailing people and saying hey I'm doing
this can you donate money to me so that
I can do this and raise money because
this is something that impacts my family
and then I find that someone is picking
up hundreds of thousands of dollars be
of the location at which the event was
held can anyone think of anything lower
than redirecting cancer money for kids
to your for-profit business it is
absolutely disgusting and people are
discussing this on the david pakman show
subreddit which you can access by going
to david pakman.com slash re d di t we
will take a break part two of our deep
dive into race and IQ is coming up next
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS